is the entire complexion of the game
great effort coming up on two minutes
remaining
Cavs hanging on to a four-point lead
shot clock at three James the drive and
foul the shot will not count James
trying to think it was a continuation
grabbed his Jersey on the drive
apparently before he gathered as Rozier
picks up his second but going back to
what Coach talked about trust your
defense
you're letting guys off the hook that's
clearly a tug of New Jersey that's a
foul then once again critical free
throws and they were sending the
double-team to get it out of his hands
[Applause]
this is that one it remains for Jason
Tatum's on his way to double
and Mark Davis clearly saw him grab that
Jersey
[Applause]
second free-throw is good back to five
[Applause]
under two to play here in game seven
Tait Aparna by Jo Smith drive stripped
of all my Smith so many big defensive
plays for the Cavaliers tonight game
drives kicks it out corner Jeff Green
3.0 misses rebound Rozier
Rozier season-opening pulls back back in
the corner sets the three pointer misses
rebound goes to Jeff Green George Hill
releases down the other end drives layup
he fights in a seven-point Cavs lead
with 1:16 remaining timeout Boston what
a gutsy pass by LeBron James well you
want to go quick
but no foul no tatum round back in the
game
steps back fires a three shot short
rebound tipped and taken by James there
comes James in the open floor James
grabbed from behind count it goal 10 and
1 and it's up to 9 with 104 remaining
LeBron James now with 34 points
[Applause]
absolutely amazing what we're witnessing
putting his team on his back takes the
contact hits the basket but an
incredible display by LeBron James mama
there goes that man and they're gonna
look at flagrant foul here and again
this crowd absolutely stunned but that
was a bad shot by Jalen Brown again like
trying to hit a home run with the three
down seven and we got to give credit to
Jeff Green the former Celtic we know
it's been documented the battles in his
life overcoming health issues an
incredible inspirational story of what
he's been able to do in the absence of
Kevin Love big-time play they are just
on the instant replay just to confirm on
the gol 10 they could look at it when
it's called the gol 10 but why does that
matter the ball went in the matter if
it's goaltending and the ball still goes
in
name's 34 points 14 rebounds 9 assists a
10-point game with just over a minute
remaining
[Applause]
Celtics need to push
[Music]
smart on the drive gets inside lays it
misses it James the rebound hooks it
away smart comes up with the play back
out Morris Morris fires up the three
that's no good rebound junior Smith and
the Cavaliers and LeBron James will do
it again a foul called with 40.5 seconds
remaining what a turnaround here in Game
seven the Celtics on the verge of their
first loss at home here in this
postseason
a stunning defeat III don't have this
all in my head about all the teams but I
would hearken to say that not no one
person has ever shouldered more and
gotten his team to the finals the lack
of help as far as consistently that
they're able to advance to the finals
I'll say it again he'll never have a
greater achievement than getting this
team to the finals meanwhile the Celtic
fans starting it on their feet and
cheering for their team that had this
improbable run and obviously now will
come up one game short of an NBA Finals
appearance because of that man as LeBron
James will make his eighth consecutive
Finals appearance you hear the chants of
let's go Celtics this has been one of
longtime Celtic fans favorite teams
they've loved this team but they were
beaten by a great player as Morris
throws it down with 32.3 remaining
and they'll foul jr. Smith and after the
work done by LeBron an appreciation from
the bench acknowledgment look at the
Pips saying Thank You Gladys
but a well done job across the ball this
is an incredible accomplishment and I
echo what coach said and I'll say when
is the national media gonna start giving
tyloo the respect he deserves for what
he's accomplished in his entire career
in Cleveland this is not an easy group
to coach they have had ups and downs
they've had a trade that really didn't
work in many respects they've been blown
out here three times deserves a lot of
credit and how ironic where defense
they've struggled all season was Jalen
Brown hits that three-pointer and the
defense was enormous in this victory
here in Game seven and now the cows will
dribble it out and Mike as much as the
Celtics have to be proud of they're
gonna rue this performance today it'll
be a tough offseason knowing how close
they came
good sportsmanship their final seconds
tick off it's over Cleveland wins Game
seven LeBron James and the Cavs do it
again
[Applause]
[Music]